we continue to to see signs of russian
escalation
including new forces arriving at the
ukrainian border
as we've said before we are in the
window when an invasion could begin at
any time should vladimir putin decide to
order it i will not comment on the
details of our intelligence information
but i do want to be clear it could begin
during the olympics
despite a lot of speculation
that it would only happen after the
olympics
as we've said before we are ready either
way
we are ready to continue
results-oriented diplomacy that
addresses the security concerns of the
united states russia and europe
consistent with our values and with the
principle of reciprocity we've continued
to make that clear to russia in close
coordination with our european allies
and partners
we are also ready to respond decisively
alongside those allies and partners
should russia choose to take military
action
our response would include severe
economic sanctions with similar packages
imposed by the european union the united
kingdom canada and other countries it
would also include changes to nato and
american force posture along the eastern
flank of nato and it would include
continued support to ukraine
the president held a secure video conf
conference today with key allies and
partners to coordinate our approach to
this crisis
the participants were the uk france
germany italy canada poland romania the
secretary general of nato and the
presidents of the european union
we have
achieved a remarkable level of unity and
common purpose from the broad strategy
down to the technical details
if russia proceeds
its long-term power and influence will
be diminished not enhanced by an
invasion
it will face a more determined
transatlantic community
it will have to make more concessions to
china
it will face massive pressure on its
economy and export controls that will
erode its defense industrial base and it
will face a wave of condemnation from
around the world
if on the other hand russia truly seeks
a diplomatic outcome it should not only
say so it should pursue that diplomatic
outcome we are prepared to do that we
have put concrete proposals on the table
they are now out there for the world to
see we're prepared to engage on them and
to discuss the principles and parameters
of european security with our european
partners and with russia
whatever happens next
the west is more united than it's been
in years nato has been strengthened the
alliance is more cohesive more
purposeful more dynamic than at any time
in recent memory
in terms of immediate next steps
president biden and his team will remain
in close contact with our allies and
partners to coordinate both on the
potential for diplomacy and on any
response that is necessary should putin
decide to order military action
we are continuing to reduce the size of
our embassy footprint in kiev
and i now want to take a moment to echo
what both president biden and secretary
blinken have already said we encourage
all american citizens who remain in
ukraine to depart immediately
we want to be crystal clear on this
point
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours
we obviously cannot predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough
and the threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
if you stay
you are assuming
risk
with no guarantee that there will be any
other opportunity to leave
and there no prospect of a u.s military
evacuation in the event of a russian
invasion
if a russian attack on ukraine proceeds
it is likely to begin with aerial
bombing and missile attacks that could
obviously kill civilians without regard
to their nationality
a subsequent ground invasion would
involve the onslaught of a massive force
with virtually no notice communications
to arrange a departure could be severed
and commercial transit halted
no one would be able to count on air or
rail or road departures once military
action
got underway now again i'm not standing
here and saying what is going to happen
or not happen i'm only standing here to
say that the risk is now high enough and
the threat is immediate enough that
prudence demands that it is the time to
leave now while commercial options
and commercial rail and air service
exist while the roads are open
the president will not be putting the
lives of our men and women in uniform at
risk by sending them into a war zone to
rescue people who could have left now
but chose not to so we're asking people
to make the responsible choice